nothing to lose need you to where you
are today I believe story is gonna make
you a star I figured it out Carrie's
libertarian perspective led to his
involvement with the internet political
magazine reasontv we have an ideology we
have a politics we have a point of view
we're libertarian were for free minds
and free markets were socially liberal
were fiscally conservative Carrie had
long been a fan of Reason magazine and
in the mid-nineties he decided to attend
one of its social functions he would
send out a postcard to area subscribers
and say you know would you come and join
the people who make their favorite
magazine for some bad wine and some bad
cheese one of the people who called up
to RSVP was Drew Carey and he said you
know I'm a subscriber i love the
magazine I'd love to come down and hang
out inspired to get more involved Kari
took courses and documentary filmmaking
and before long he was producing topical
documentaries for reason TV but is New
York City the new California let's see
smoking ban check trans fat ban check
bands on aluminum bats check ban on
straddling a bike wearing in light
skates or drinking coffee on a subway
check check check it's not about
stand-up it's not about glibness so it's
actually about getting into an issue and
working through it and and producing a
really thoughtful and insightful piece
of work so here i am in front of the
pharmacy in west hollywood it's on Santa
Monica Boulevard right by santa monica
and fairfax really busy street busy
is one of over 100 places Los Angeles
where if you have a note from your
doctor get rare flowers fine herbs
organic medicine in other words medical
marijuana smell that smell it's the
smell of freedom